Donald E knuth presents a simple proof
of Tamara's theorem the set of binary
trees with n nodes forms a lattice under
a one-way associative law as a
consequence of the associative law the
product of a B times C is equal to the
product of a and B see any two ways of
parenthesis in a formula are equal when
variables appear in the same order from
left to right using the one-way
associative law the product of a B times
C can be rewritten as the product of a
and B see this can be construed as a
reduction yielding a right hand side
less than the left hand side after
presenting a simple encoding of Brian
Airy trees Knuth defines an ordering on
the encoding right rotating a tree
increases its encoding with respect to
the ordering the relation and the
encoding is yield a simple non
distributive lattice on binary trees
title of my talk today is is called the
associative law I guess you have to come
to a computer science lecture in order
to hear a lecture about the associative
law because it's so basic in mathematics
everyone stops talking about the
associative law in high school and
mathematic good of science we're still
interested in it and in fact it's one of
the I'm going to try to try to make you
all thrilled about the associative law
right now in general when I'm giving
these when I'm giving these talks
they're based on things that I encounter
as I'm preparing for volume 4 of the art
of computer programming but today is
something that really belongs in volume
1 in a sense that if I had known about
the things I'm talking about today when
I was in the 60s when I was right
the first volume I would certainly have
put them in there because that because
that's where we introduced the concept
of binary trees you know computer
computer scientists one of the most
important data structures that we use
all the time is binary trees and and so
of course binary trees got right into
the to the first volume of my books and
and pseudo-scientists well we love
binary trees let's face it minorities
are beautiful or something I thought
that hadn't been hadn't been studied in
great detail in mathematics but but but
but the more we we learn about computer
applications tomorrow we where we're
happy we know more facts about binary
trees how the the facts that I'm that
I'm going to talk about are some things
that that are true about binary trees
that I didn't know 30 years ago okay or
I didn't know in fact until until this
summer I knew I knew that that some of
these theorems were true but I but like
I was I unable to understand the proofs
the the main things that I'm going to be
talking about today actually were
approved by a French mathematician named
tamari dove tamari in his PhD thesis and
i think it was like 1953 and then he and
another french mathematician high of
freedmen published in early 60s a
simplified proof but it was still very
complicated in and and i always thought
i would put on my list of things to
understand someday but it was so long
and complicated like i never was able to
get up the courage to do it well then
temari and long in early 70s found a
simpler proof yet and so that proof was
actually just a few pages long and by
known about it i would have in fact read
it instead but i didn't know about that
simpler proof until this summer so then
went this summer when i looked at their
simpler proof it occurred to me oh but
wait i can make it really simple and
nice and
and that's when I decided to to give
this pop so but what what am I talking
about well okay so first of all a binary
tree we know is it is a it is is
something which has nodes and each node
has either has has two things coming out
of it or none so this one has none
coming out and this has two and we can
we constrain these we can swing these
out in various wait now the when I talk
about enemies in this lecture n is going
to be the number of of the of the nodes
that have two things coming out these
are the internal nodes of a binary tree
there's also external nodes and there's
always n plus 1 external nodes and
that's where we can hang data we can
also put data in internal nodes but in
would we do everything depending on the
application now being a lot of
algorithms based on binary trees use the
idea of a rotation let me see let me
give a more general binary tree here
slightly more general so let's actually
I should let you write one for me so
that so that you so that's not
pre-planned but I mean but I do have a
good one in mind well what the heck
let's just take a cup let's just draw a
few more okay there's a binary tree
humming that's how many notes as it ever
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 okay now now beyond the
idea of a rotation in a binary tree is
that we that we have a sub structure
that looks like this there's some treat
alpha hanging down here and some 3 beta
hanging
they're in some pre gamin down here this
might be our complicated or they might
be simple they might be empty alpha beta
gamma might be empty anyway this if we
if we convert this into into the binary
tree that looks like this with alpha
here beta and gamma here then we call
this a rotation to the right and then if
we if I move the arrow on the other way
its rotation to the left okay now this
is the most business because its
simplest thing you can do to a binary
tree and get another binary tree with
the same number of nodes in it and it
also has a great property that is that
the that the order of nodes in symmetric
order doesn't change now the symmetric
order of nodes of a power of a binary
tree is when we read them from left to
right you know this would be one two
three four five six six seven eight you
the binary what you do is you you first
read the things to the left of the root
in symmetric order then you read the
root then you read everything to the
right and in symmetric order or if we
projected all of these things down
without any lines crossing it would be
the order in which the ink in which they
hit the horizon and you see that that in
this tree if alpha you know alpha comes
first and beta than gamma in the
symmetric order and same in this Fitness
on the right so you know a lot of
applications will have been the numbers
the data in the tree will be numbers
that are in increasing order in
symmetric order so this is a fundamental
operation that's often used to balance a
tree to make a tree so that all the
leaves are are as close to the you know
the number of levels is small if we want
or or in some cases we like to unbalance
the tree and get the number of levels
large anyway whatever now you know we
also use binary trees to to represent
algebraic expressions and so if i put if
i put letters on the bottom here ABCDE
f g h i then this would be an algebraic
expression that says we want to multiply
B by sea and we want to multiply that by
a and then we want to multiply that
thing by de and then we want to multiply
the whole business times the right
subtree which is f g h times i right
it's a kind of a mess but that's the
that's another you know so this
represents an algebraic formula in that
case if you see what happens to this
port this rotation means the rotation
says that alpha beta gamma is being
rotated over into alpha beta gamma so
here's this is why i call this talk the
associative love a disclosure that love
is application of a changing of changing
a formula that has binary operator from
this form to this form is to
mathematicians is the associative law or
changing the parenthesis Bureau
scientist it means rotating the binary
tree now I drew this here as if as if
the note on the top where the rotation
is taking place is the root of the tree
that doesn't have to be true you can do
a rotation anywhere the middle of a tree
so I could rotate for example well
almost anyway male 3 anywhere that that
you have a but I have a substructure I
couldn't rotate here because a is not a
note k is just a leak but but if I want
to rotate here for example then this one
would come in this one would come up and
this would move down be wouldn't so so
what would happen a would come up bc
would attach itself to this to this guy
and so on so we would rotate that would
be taking this part of the thing and and
putting the vc over with the de flying
associative law in the middle of the
formula so you don't have to apply a
social lonely at the top okay now
interesting thing though is when we talk
about in a one-way associative law
instead of saying that the associate
value is equality let's say that instead
the arrow there's a definite thing thing
that this one oh we might say is
unstable and wants to go to this one
okay now this would this defines not
equality of expressions but an
inequality of expressions in fact though
I want to I want to regard this one is
larger than this one we're going to be
finite and ordering non binary trees
where for this one's going to be a small
tree this is going to be a large tree
and if we ever do a rotation to the
right it's going to make it larger and
then the anal going the other way would
make it smaller so so so it turns out
that we get a nice nice ordering between
binary trees when we like when we
consider one way associative love this I
I ran across this first when I was when
I was playing with something I've got to
be called the Knuth bendix algorithm
where we're trying to to derive
consequences of axioms and and the idea
is that you want to prove that two
things if you want you want to decide
whether to formulas can be proved equal
based on a certain number of axioms and
the truth bendix algorithm sometimes
work sometime doesn't when it does work
it gives you a set of reductions of
one-sided transformations that you make
and the idea is that once you got these
reductions you apply the reductions over
and over again to both sides of the
formula that you wish to approve or
equal or not if and you keep on doing
this and it turns out that the will
never get into a loop so each side will
reduce to a particular form where no
reductions apply anymore then then the
two things are equal if and only if the
reduce formula on the left is equal to
the reduced formula on the right so this
gives a simple way to test whether youth
weather is possible to prove equality of
two formula now if the only axiom that
you're given to the canoe sibenik system
if you're the only accent metric that
you give is the associative law
a b c equals eight times quantity bc
then knuth bendix algorithm grinds out
one reduction and this is the reduction
it grinds out and so it says that you
can prove that two formulas are equal by
the associative law if and only if it
reduces the same thing which means that
if I keep on replying this applying its
operation over and over again to some
tree eventually I get to a tree that
can't be reduced anymore and then you
and then when you have two trees in that
form then then they're equal if and only
if one of the things that when I first
learned the associative law in in high
school it wasn't immediately being like
I was given that a b c is equal to a
times bc but one of the things that have
to prove is maybe that a times bc
quantity x be e is this equal to some
messy thing well what's the a B times C
D prime Z and how would you prove that
this was equal to this and you're
allowed to use this kind of operation a
B and C are variables not constant and
well you could player you could you
could fill around and get from one to
the other but the easiest way is to is
to keep is to keep using one-way
reductions instead of going from left to
right I'm just take this all the way
down until finally this becomes a times
B times C times de in a sequence of
reductions and this also becomes a times
B times C times D in sequence of
reductions and so these are equal
neither equal therefore the original
forms were equal well that's so so
that's one special case of compendex
elegant any of you interested in
pursuing what I'm talking about today
further I've got some conjectures that
maybe this is going to all generalize to
arbitrary axiom systems that for which
the appendix other than work but let's
stick with the simplest case now is one
side of the associative law okay so we
got it we've got an ordering on binary
trees and we'll say that this tree is
bigger in history
and whenever whenever I do a rotation I
get an ordering now the theorem that
samaya proof in his PhD thesis in the 30
cookies was that the partial ordering is
actually a lattice a lattice means that
it that the ordering is kind of nice if
you can take greatest lower bounds and
least upper bounds in the order this
that this means that if I have if I have
our two trees at t1 and t2 and I can
compute the for example another treaty
three that is greater than or equal to t
that heavier is to say larger than or
equal to t1 and t2 both and it's the
smallest that's harder than both of them
so anything that's larger than t1 and t2
is also larger than T larger than or
equal to t three and conversely anything
larger equal t3 is if it's a fact 42
elitism this relation of greater than on
trees is is transitive if I can get from
from one tree to another by a sequence
of rotation and I can get from that
second one to a third one by more
rotation i get from the first to the
third just like continue doing the
rotation so so the interesting thing was
though that there is actually a least
element that's greater than or equal to
2 and similarly for less than or equal
because it forms the lattice and means
that I can also take greatest lower
bound so that there will be some other
trees that's less than or equal to both
t1 and t2 and and any and it's the
largest of all those that are less than
or equal they will now but but but the
hard thing was proving that how would
you and and not only that but how would
you into it how would you understand
given two trees what's the what are the
trees that that are are greater than it
are greater than both of them but but as
small as possible being greater than
both of them and and
how on earth would you compute their
their least upper bound when lattice
when we have a lattice operation we
usually call it the meat in the joint
I'll it's not the same as a joint in
database theory but the meat is that is
going smaller and the joint is going
larger and and so the meat of two
elements of a lattice is written this
way in the joint written this way and
what would talk more about lasses in a
minute first let me let me show you how
we're going to how we're going to go
from binary trees in a natural way to
understand which is partial ordering it
so this is the joint and this is to me
and this is let this this is the least
this is the greatest lower bound this is
the least upper bound on two things in a
ladder ok let's out now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to encode a binary
tree in a very simple way and it
probably was in Volume one we get at
every at every node I'm going to write
down the number of nodes in the right
subtree so here there's one here 0 here
0 here here there is one knowing the
right subtree how many here 1230 10 now
the encoding for that tree is is we read
off these numbers in the symmetric order
from left to right so that would be 1 0
10 3 100 should be eight if there's up
if there's eight if there's any knows
there's going to be a n numbers here and
and this is the here they are the right
subtree sizes and this is an encoding
arm that anyway I can take any binary
tree and get these numbers now suppose
that I just had those numbers but
somebody covers up the tree he says what
you know
what was that tree can I reconstruct it
okay well these are the right subtree
sizes of the nodes in increasing order
so how am I going to think how am I
going to figure out what's going to
happen well for example this node here
has three it means that there are three
other nodes affect the next three have
to be its right subtree so the next
three nodes after this one are going to
be the are going to be the subtree
numbers dark but I can draw this arrow
here covering three guys to the right
saying that these are going to be in the
subtree under this one similarly this
this one says that this is it sort of
protects that zero here this one's not
going to cover this viewer this one's
gonna go like that oh so I claim that
the root of the tree is going to have to
be this one and at these and either two
subtrees that that that sort of hang out
to the left in other ways given a
sequence of these numbers we can we can
always convert it into blocks like this
where we draw from every from every
number we go we cover that many guys to
the right and and these are going to
nest that they're never going to cut it
so we're going to be an arrow coming out
from under here into another one you see
I couldn't have a two sitting here
because that would mean that somebody
would have a subtree of two things but
but but but this would all have to be
part of the subtree of the other three
okay well um now why is it true that
that this has to be the root of the tree
well because this one because if
somebody if somebody included is this as
a sub tree would have to have more than
three nodes in it and three is the
biggest number so that's that was too
easy if I see if I started out with you
went with it with a more complicated
example but the largest number isn't
always the isn't always the root of the
tree but in this particular case it is
so anyway that identifies three has to
be the root of the tree then then trim
for the right subtree I have to do a 100
now how do I figure out the 100 oh
that's not so that's going to be the sub
tree that goes over here and well 100 I
somehow I'm going to have to figure out
that 0 is the root of that and one and
the other 10 is the left subtree and so
they left sub tree would look like that
and similarly for the 10 10 we're going
to figure out that that turns out to be
that the root turns out to be a 10 and
that to the left of that is another 10
did I get it right yeah okay good well
Wow how does the theory ok so anyway
these these numbers not it's not really
very hard to figure out that you can
reconstruct the tree from these numbers
but let's let's take a look at what the
numbers are so there's a sequence of
numbers r 1 r sub n these are the right
subtree counts and what are the
conditions that they satisfy well the
first condition may satisfy is that our
sub K is less than or equal n minus K RN
has to be 0 RN minus one has to be 0 or
one hour one has to be between one and n
minus 1 between 0 and n minus 1 now well
that's clear because the everything in
the right subtree there are n minus K
guys to the right and so and if our K
represents the number of people in the
right subtree they all lie to the right
that then n minus K can only happen if
if you're using everybody to the right
so this is this is an obvious condition
that has to be
true now that's necessary not another
condition is a little trickier but also
true and that is if RK is is equal to J
that means that we have J guys in the
right subtree that means I was going to
draw an arrow that's the next J things
then then our k plus 1 is less than or
equal j minus 1 and r k plus j is less
than or equal to 0 and RK plus 2 is less
than equal j minus 2 and so on now well
that's what I said when I drew an arrow
from this guy to three guys to the right
and the three then the next three
numbers had to be such that that their
arrows aren't going to protrude has the
the arrow that's that's that's above
them another way to say that is the is
the next J numbers are k plus 1 up to RK
plus J these are the numbers for some
for the right subtree of node k and so
they have to be a proper sequence as if
they put a box around them these would
have to these would have to be the AR
coating of some sub tree and so that
would have to satisfy condition 1 and
condition one would would say that the
first one is less than J minus 1 and x 1
less than J minus 2 and so on because
because n is equal to J in that cake so
this is just say so so another condition
one was August condition 2 is secondary
obvious that would say that you know
it's a special case files from condition
one when i look at sub trees and so you
might say well then i'm going to have to
go to condition 3 which talks about sub
sub trees and and and and keep on going
but turns out no just these two
conditions are necessary and sufficient
that is if we have these if we have
these two these conditions then we can
repin it then we can always reconstruct
the tree now you can you can also put
this into another form
another equivalent form so conditioned
to is is also the same as saying if one
less than or equal to i less than or
equal to R sub k then r sub k plus gotta
plan ahead I forget the if one less than
or equal I less than or equal R sub K
implies R sub k plus I is less than or
equal to R sub K and minus I isn't it
right yeah r sub K minus I and so I can
I might as well use it forget this
because it works like 20 as well okay so
this is the condition that our k plus 1
is less than or equal to R K minus one
hour k plus 2 and so on going up to up
to that so here's another and another
way to to say this disc and the second
condition but it really means that I
just look at the next J number and and
they have to form a encoding sequence
too so they have to set it right now
with this properties to the whole
sequence okay so now if we do that now
now I want to say hi I can if I if I
have numbers that satisfy this I can
construct a binary tree uniquely that
that has these as the sizes of the right
subtrees okay well I won't go through
formal proof it's intuitive but we get
the idea that we think there is a
largest value of K for which the
Equality I'm sorry I smallest value of K
for which equality holds it certainly
holds true for K equals end the last guy
is always 0 and that there might be
earlier ones where is ok equals n minus
okay in that case I take the very first
okay and that's going to be the root of
the tree and and so and so then it's all
nodes take k to be minimum for which k
is minimum for which are K equals n
minus K and then I then I have RK
sitting here and then I have numbers
here and I and I want to prove that
these two guys are going to represent
the left subtree in the right subtree of
the binary tree so so the numbers on the
right are going to satisfy conditions
one and two because the condition to
reduces the condition one in the case in
that particular case and condition to
still holds in the substring if the
holes in the screen on the left hand
side I have to show I have to show that
are three for example is is less than or
equal I have to show the condition one
holds in the left hand side so I have to
show that our 3 is less than or equal to
k minus let's see i got k minus 1 guys
here so that would be k minus 1 minus 3
i'd have to show that our 3 is less than
or equal to at the show that r 1 is less
than or equal to k minus 2 r 2 is less
VK minus weaker are three listen k minus
4 and so on up to our k minus 1 is 0 how
would I show that our 3 is less than or
equal k minus 1 minus 3 well if not
because what are well let's see
okay so I 3 plus k minus 3 if it does if
not if I three were you know if not then
it would be like you know then it then
it would be K minus three or more so
then I could talk about our 03 plus k
minus 3 and I could call j I mean this
would be I k minus 3 is less than or
equal is less than or equal to our three
and then so I apply it I k minus 3 this
is our three and so then it would say
that our sub K minus 3 sorry r sub 3
plus k minus 3 is less than or equal to
R 3 minus I hmm and that's less than or
equal to n minus 3 minus K minus 3
so let me see where am I doing here this
is equal n minus K but this is our k RK
is this mrs. any okay so this is in mind
this is equal to n minus K so this is
equal to R K again but fired by my
assumption so equality has told
everywhere and this way this would imply
in particular that are three was equal
to n minus three but I assume that K was
the minimum okay long proof that proved
that that proves that this works so if
you have conditions one and two you can
always construct a tree from them and
the tree that was the only tree that
that does it to receive you see that
that's that's unique okay now let's look
at what a rotation does what is a
rotation view in this encoding scheme so
cause I have a rotation and I got are
things here which means that out that
gamma has our guys in it our nodes are
are in gamma and suppose I have Q here
so their work you internal those in beta
and now I'm I rotate that and I get
another tree with alpha here and beta
gamma here now in inside alpha beta
nothing is happening to the sizes of
their right subtrees if this is in the
middle of some bigger tree nothing has
happened to the size of anybody else's
right subtrees either oh but what
happening now the size of this subtree
how many how many nodes either well as
to hear are there one more there so
that's Q plus r plus 1 and this is still
ours still still gamma
so so what's happened in a rotation is
that exactly one of the subtree counts
has gone up and it went up from q 2 q +
r plus 1 it was definitely bigger okay
so certainly if I have if I have some
row represents a son tree and and then I
rotate this goes to let's say row goes
to row prime then this is true then it's
Q that rho is less than or equal to Rho
Prime component-wise the let me use this
less than or equal on a row here is
going to stand for a sequence of numbers
like 10 10 3 101 and I do a rotation any
rotation whatsoever in that tree
whatever I get I'm going to get
something that component wise the first
component is less of rho is less than
the first component of row prime second
component less than or equal and so on
in fact it's going to be equal
everywhere except in one place but so
it's quite clear than if I do a sequence
of rotations then I then then it stays
component wise larger ok now the the
beautiful thing and otherwise the women
are given this thought is that it's also
it also is it's true the other way in
other words it rho is less than or equal
to rho prime or let say Rho rotates with
a star in here that says I a star means
that i apply rotation 0 what times one
time to tie any number of times if and
only if it is component wise less than
in its it when I when I read the numbers
so if i look at the if i look at the
encoding of it of any two binary trees
and i compare them I compare r 1 to r 1
prime are too dark to prime and so on if
I always
get less than or equal then I could get
the the second tree from the first by by
doing rotations only to the right but if
any one of them is less obviously could
now one way is obviously since this way
so in a rotation always increases but
now you have to show the other way that
if I take any two binary trees and one
is there in the other then there's there
is a way to actually rotate the guy into
the other one I'll prove that in a
minute what will the first derive some
consequences of it you see you see why
that's interesting but that but that is
is a fact and will soon see why it's
true and that and and so this is a very
nice characterization you just look at
these at these right subtree numbers and
then and this and we first saw knowing
the right subtree numbers is enough to
know the tree and secondly if you know
the right subtree numbers of two trees
you can tell whether one is less than or
equal to the other one is obtainable
from the other by rotations or not it's
just just look at the at at them
component wise and each component has to
be greater than or equal okay but now we
can also get a corollary and that is the
joint of the meat I'm sorry of two trees
is equal to on the minimum of the two
component wise if i take if i take the
encoding of two different binary trees
and if i take the minimum component by
component independent of anything else i
claim i get encoding of a binary tree
and then therefore it would have to be
you would have to be the greatest lower
bound okay let's see why that is first
of all suppose I have sequence than r1
r2
RN and another another one r 2 prime so
these are these are two in coatings of
binary trees so it's equivalent to
saying a binary trees is given by by a
sequence of number this is roll this is
rope rack and and so uh so this
satisfied conditions one and two our
prime satisfies conditions wanted to now
I just want to show that minimum that
the minimum of of the two minimum of r1
r1 run up to minimum of rn rn prime
adjust sequence also satisfies
conditions one and two if I can show
that it satisfies division 1 and 2 then
it's then it represents a binary tree
okay so well that's obvious i mean take
take condition 1 RK is less than or
equal is our prime R K prime is less
than equal this so the minimum is
certainly less than in the other hand
here let's suppose that RK is is it you
know well I got it I can do it in this
form so suppose I is less than or equal
to the minimum of our k & R K prime then
I have to show that the minimum of this
is less than or equal to the minimum on
the right hand side but the butt well
it's obvious I mean a minimum of RK + I
+ RK plus I time is less than or equal
to the minimum of our RK minus i-r k
prime minus I because you take the
minimum two things this one is less than
or equal to this is one less than equal
it and this is just the minimum of our
KR k prime minus I so addition two holes
as well so 0 is if if these two
conditions hold then so does so does it
also holds for the minim doesn't know
for the maximum we talked about the
maximum in a minute but it certainly
holds for the minimum
okay so so I would this is this is a
simple operation now to do component
wise on any two in coatings and it's
going to give us another tree so that's
a binary tree the significance that
binary tree is it is less than or equal
to this one and it's less than equal to
this one therefore this binary tree will
rotate into this one and this one it's a
it's a common less than or equal to both
of them and it's the largest such
because if anybody is less than both of
them it has to be less than it has to be
less than or equal this one this is the
biggest we could possibly get and
anything else less than both of them
would have to be less than or equal to
the minimum of the two guys so that's
the that's the proof that there is a
greatest lower bound I haven't proved
that I improve the other side of this of
this love it as soon as I prove that
then I've got a greatest lower bound to
get to get a least upper bound we do the
same thing but we we use left subtree
encoding instead of right subtree
encoding and then we take the minimum of
those and and and i could take the
insult so there's a duality between left
and right you switch left and right
unless then goes to greater than left
rotation goes to write rotations this
clip left and right you get you can
equivalence theorem and you're taking
the minimum of those in coatings will
give you a left and a left subtree
encoding for for a tree and that will be
less than or equal to in the dual
version so it's greater than or equal
than the other folks oaks and we can
compute the the least upper bound in a
similar way but using left subtree sizes
instead of right subtree side now i
still have to prove this this
back here and up it's not it's not hard
now I'm going to I'm going to work on
another problem so I'm going to erase
this i'm going to say suppose this is
less than or equal to this but not equal
and i'm going to so now i'm going to try
to prove i'm going to try to prove this
directions i'm going to try to prove if
that I if I have to two sequences this
one less than or equal this one then I'm
going to prove that I can rotate this
tree into this tree that there is a
rotation so let's suppose that r1 equals
R 1 prime until we get our k minus 1
equals R K minus 1 prime but then we
have a definite less than situation and
then after that are k plus 1 is less
than or equal our k plus 1 prime and so
on up until our case we all the way up
to our sub n is less than or equal arts
of in front so I have a less than or
equal situation on the right equals to
the left and definitely less than right
here and and now I want to show that I
can I can do the rotation to let the
idea will be simply to say that there's
a rotation that will increase our k and
intend and and keep it less than or
equal R K prime so if I can find some
tree if I can do a rotation here that
will increase our k but it won't change
any of the other remember a rotation we
change is one of the hours at a time so
sorry so if i find a rotation so well
i'll do a rotation at this node wherever
it is I want to prove that it has a that
its parent is to is a right parent that
this isn't that that k node k has to be
a left child of its parent and that if i
do a rotation at k bring it up then new
value that it has will be less than or
equal to R K prime and and if I can do
that well then I've gotten closer i
rotated this one I've gotten closer to
this one because something increased and
so I can keep on repeating this over and
over again eventually I get there okay
so so so this is the crew
stuff is saying that if i get a rotation
and i made progress in this private
young I can't thought this can't go on
forever because these are finite numbers
and just so so okay so that's the way
we're now so if we look at the at the
right encoding it turns out that well I
have to show that they said that that k
node k it is I could do a rotation there
I mean I have this node the case noted
in symmetric Gordon is and it looks like
this and then it's got it I want to show
that has a parent up here and so that I
can do a rotation and then there will be
a certain number of nodes here this will
be our of where elements called el L is
equal to see what's that what notice is
at what is the elf nota this is not the
case node the right subtree here is has
our K nodes in and so l is equal to k
plus R sub K and +1 or is it if RK is
zero that means there's nobody here than
L yeah it's yeah so Ellis is que pasar k
plus 1 it's the end of soap so if we
look at it in the sequence form our RK
is sitting here and we can we draw draw
an arrow over the next r sub K nodes and
then R sub L is the node that follows
after it in the in the sequence I think
this is this geometric picture is easy
way the easy way to look at it so I've
got so I've got this kind of a picture
well now if I do a rotation then @ @ k
i'm not going to write out the proof
above what it's it's easy for you to get
to to find by yourself if you if you do
it but it follows from conditions one
and two so remember condition who said
that as I draw this arrow in here every
inside the box is is it is another
sequence that satisfies conditions one
and two but with the size of the subject
is this this sequence here represents
some sub tree so now okay the fact that
are that the fact that I I never used I
never use this I never use the fact that
our K prime is a larger value here never
there that are K prime is another tree
that actually works and it's bigger our
k prime is bigger than our case so the
arrow coming out of the second one
shoots out to the right so that means
there's an enclosing box out here that
that is the the the the constraint and
how big r sub k can get and that
constraint is is not tight when I want
to draw this error because our k prime
also meets the constraint our K prime
satisfies this condition too so our k
prime can't be RK can't be too large and
therefore RL which which sits inside
this box is also under the same
constraint that's going to be that's
going to be the key that proves that
there is that there is a node above it
the the only note the only nodes that
don't have a right that is whose parent
is not to the right are the ones for
which when you draw the arrow the arrow
went as far as it could go so if there's
another arrow above it that the arrow
goes all the way to the right and if the
error comes down like this and there's
something then this guy is going to be a
parent of of this sub tree but if it
comes all the way to the right then then
then it doesn't have a parenting subject
so so that's my desk idea that this this
value here r sub L is is known to be not
too large it's because our k prime puts
a bound on this this this guy can be at
most are K prime minus 1 RP prime minus
2 this can be at most are K prime minus
R
x plus one so when you put the whole
thing together you do get in fact the
lead exactly the inequality that you
need that proves the theorem but now
let's try to intuit it and and figure
out what it means so for example I've
drawn all the here I got a picture that
shows you all the trees when N equals 4
n equals 4 so I have I have value no 3 2
1 0 is the is the largest tree that you
can get that 3 2 1 0 that's that that's
a tree that that's you can't rotate
anymore this is the only one that
educate can't rotate from and at the
bottom here 0000 this this is the
extreme 0000 that you can keep only
thing you can do is rotate so this is
the bottom element very smallest this is
the largest visit top element and then
since i have four numbers but the last
number is always 0 i can draw them in
three dimensions the other three thought
so you can use you can you can imagine
that this is a three-dimensional picture
here with and so like I gave the x y&z
coordinates and and going up is a
rotation or going up in any in either X
Y or Z Direction is a rotation so we can
go from this tree to either the 1000
both 0 0 100 100 ok so the 14 14 threes
are now uncoded by strings of there by
the right subtrees here think of an
analogy imagine another lattice it's a
it's easier to think of consider all the
divisors of 360 the 360 if I if I Dennis
right is 2 cubed times three squared
times 5 8 times 5 is 40 times not yeah
and and so if other to the first power
so all the divisors of 360 we can we can
encode them by how many twos the re
number 33 element 53 enough so the
divisors of 360 can be represented as a
sequence r1 r2 r3 till or are two hours
well anyway three numbers when the first
one is zero one two or three the next
one is zero one or two for how many 3s
there are and how many 520 or one so we
would get a picture something like that
but it would be it would be a complete
with brick so then I draw up here the
corresponding thing for when you have a
multiple of five so gives you ought you
know so I get something like this if I
do it did I blow it it's not too bad
this is going to be the top of the brick
and then we got rid of lines going down
so so there's some there's a great here
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 19 so this would be 0 0
0 0 again 0 1 0 0 this would be 1000 and
then up here is 0 0 1 forget the last
prom phone excuse me and at the top at
the very top is 321 it's a similar thing
but we have all all possible coordinates
you hear it here it's this farce thing
we have to leave out the coordinates
that don't satisfy condition to 12 all
right so so this is a lattice in fact
that might be why they started calling
them lattices in the first place because
this is like it you know this looks like
there's all the lattice points in a in a
solid and in the when we talk about two
numbers that are divided at 360 we talk
about their greatest common divisor the
least common
multiple the greatest common divisor we
obtained by taking minimum component
wise how many powers of 2 divided to
think how many powers the three and so
on least common multiple we take max
calm phone and what now now in this case
if we take but what does it mean when
you in this case we we got only a part
of that brick so in this lattice what
happens when we when we want to take the
the joint of two treats the the
corresponding thing to least common
multiple or the or the least upper bound
arm and the answer is well you take the
max component wise but then you have to
go up with that that doesn't necessarily
satisfy editions 1 and 2 so then you
have to find all but you look at all the
things that do satisfy conditions one
and two and you find the smallest of
those you take the minimum of all of
them component wise so you take the set
of all of the guys who are greater than
or equal to the max component wise and
take the intersection of all those and
and you know the minimum of all those
and that gives you the value I called
you another way to get it by supply left
sub trees with you which is faster but
this is uh there's another way to do it
so so so it's okay to two trees and you
want to take their there recently you
want to get their least upper bound well
you can you can look at the max compound
wise and you see if it see if it appears
here if it doesn't appear here well you
got to go up to something that does but
the least one that does will be unique
there won't be two that are that there
that are there okay so that that's
because it's the lattice and and the
proof is by using the the other
calculation by means of left subtree how
so in some ways this is ok now this
analogy might give you the wrong idea
about trees because the lattice of
divisors is a distributive lattice it
satisfies the distributive law between
the loves and globes but this is not a
distributive lattice dislike this
lattice does not satisfy the
distributive law between these superb on
engraved logo but I think that this that
the lettuces you get from binary trees
are probably the most interesting
lattices that are not distributed and
you know the textbook examples this is
that this would be that I think the best
of all the lattices that you think that
are not distributed this one will be the
one that has the most neat property now
other things to observe here is that if
you add to add the numbers here the sum
of all the arse in a distributive
lattice the sum of all the components is
is there is a it turns out to be the
distance 2000 but every time you go
every time you take a step you increase
by one with some of the components so
this three two one here is is six steps
away from 000 and by all past whatever
path you take you know you always go
down by exactly one but in a non
distributive lattice that doesn't happen
but the sum of these numbers does have
an interpretation to the length of the
longest path 2000 because you can always
you can see that if you pick off that if
you pick up the the numbers from the
right to the left so three two one will
go to 3200 gotta sit here here it is and
then 3200 2310 they're into here and
then down here there's always a and this
is this is true for trying to you if I
do the rotations you know in a dumb way
I can do I can rotate it so that exactly
one of the ice was down by one the
rightmost are that's 90 goes down by one
each time okay so that's an
interpretation of the Sun but now the
the the distance 2000 is another thing
that's easy to characterize and it's and
you can do this in terms of the number
of blocks of a top-level blocks here not
when I top-level block I mean when I
draw an arrow I these two together and
so there are three top level box here if
I had 0 0 0 that would be three left
zero by itself is a block but then if I
out of 10 this week this would combine
it so this has four blocks if there are
K blocks the number of the distance 20
is n minus K and it's obvious because
every rotation if we look at rotations
in terms of blocks it's a it's easy to
interpret it namely I had a rotation
which had the value few was sitting here
and then that was I was drawn over a
black then I had an are here and that
was grown over another block that was
before the rotation and then this this
sits inside some some larger some larger
encoding this was before I rotation
after the rotation what happened I got Q
plus r plus 1 and so everything else
stayed the same inside but the but the
number of blocks decreased by 1 and so
every time you do a rotation you
increase you decrease the number of
blocks by one unless this was already in
living inside of some other Block in
which case told on with life stays the
same so that so if you've got if you've
got three blocks you start out with end
blocks and you end up with three blocks
of the oh you could do it in n minus
three steps because each time you you
lose one block so so it's easy to see
the distance to 0 is the number of
blocks in just which is also the path
along along the subtree so the shortest
distance from any place 20 is at most n
minus 1 another thing you can notice in
this picture is that every every vertex
has degree n there's always end things
there's the up degree in the down degree
but the sum of the up degree is you know
going increasing X Y Z and the dawn
degrees the other way but the sum is
always three and that's true in general
the sum is always n if I would look at
this at this construction and that's
because I'm sorry n minus 1 and that's
because there are n minus 1 nodes that
aren't the root of and so you can do a
rotation at any of those it'll either be
a left rotation
right rotation now when you talk about
lattices it gives you extra extra
intuitions and things that you can do
about about trees that otherwise you
couldn't do it you might actually what's
the good of all this and people talk for
example we have prime numbers in when we
can for the divisors it we can talk
about being the the joint irreducible in
the meat irreducible which correspond to
powers of primes in the case of divisor
lattice so the same cut so these are
notes that I've checked here this is
this would correspond to 248 this would
be 39 this would be five those are
divisors if I know how many times these
divisors divide a number then I can
figure out a for two numbers then I can
figure out their GCD the same thing
holds in a lattice that is there's a
kind of a factorization theorem you know
lattice that says that any in the case
of trees this would say that any tree
can be written as the join of join
irreducible trees and any tree can be
written as the meat of meat irreducible
trees so what are the joint irreducible
treats the join a reducible trees are
are the ones that have nonzero in
exactly one component exactly as as
they're so so here's a journey of
invincible trees these are the joint
irreducible tree now the meaty reducible
trees are there's also a 6-meter
reducible treason and what you what you
do is you start out with let me this is
too small example too long to illustrate
it so let's take a larger suppose I have
about seven notes and I start out with
six but then a 10-1 all the way down
this would be the top element of the
lattice and and I and then I I take some
sub interval and I zap it which means
I decrease it down as small as I keek
Reese until it ends with zero and and
all the things that you get by zapping
those are the meat irreducible and so i
can represent i can represent an
arbitrary tree like this one as the meat
of meaty reducible so the prime factors
of this tree and since are the things i
would get bike by zapping i could take
this is this is one could this is a
eight seven six five four three two one
zero and if let then here I I use app
xap here so that just gives me a 10 7 6
5 4 3 2 1 0 and then here I'm going to
get done seven six five four I think
3100 I just have to zap they're here and
here and now I take the minimum of these
component wise I get my 10 10 me too so
Luke's all the meat of these three trees
in the minnow is this one and so in some
sense this is a prime factorization of
the tree so I would give this another
way to look at trees and we can we can
think about operations about binary
trees in a way that would have not been
clear before one last thing I want to
mention is that it's been is that a lot
of people want is the interpretation in
terms of triangulations of polygons so
there's a versa the number of binary
trees is Catalan number of the there are
five there were 14 here for example and
with three knows there are five with two
nodes or two so that goes 125 1442 very
famous sequence and the reason is famous
is that there are some 80 different
counterfoil problems known that all use
that all have catalog numbers as the
solution as to how many ways there are
to do it and so for every one of these
interpretations there's a corresponding
notation
think course binded associate look
correspond to the note the idea of a
rotation when you when you put it in in
the in that interpretation in that
comment oral interpretation and one of
the nicest got comet or interpretations
is in terms of polygons where we where
we thought we talked about triangulation
of a polygon this is one triangulation
of the polygon if the putt if the
vertices of the polygon our ABC are if
we call the sides and give given letters
and then and then we have the base and
we leave it off then we can we can get a
binary tree in the following way we
multiply B by see that and so so that's
bc here then we take that and we
multiply by a that gives us this line so
each diagonal line corresponds to a node
in the tree then here is a product of d
times e and then if we multiply that by
F we get this one and then finally this
this is the connection so they so
there's a there's a correspondence
between putting the diagonals in a
polygon till you have triangles left and
a binary tree and the I the if you see
say what's a rotation in this case but
it just turns out to erasing one of the
one of the one of the diagonals and
putting in the other one and that's
called a flip operation and people so
who people who do computational geometry
triangulations are very important
American ounces and but a lot of
operations are based on this flip
operation inside of inside of thing and
there's a there's a right flip and a
left lip depending on whether the know
that you're flipping it whether
diagonally is sort of cutting the method
right or right to left so you get a
lattice of polygons on triangulations
and if we now ignore the difference
between between left and right and just
look at this as a graph undirected graph
this is a graph where every vertex has
degree n minus one and one of the
important questions that have been
studied for example in connection with
with something called splay trees is the
mineral number of rotations to get from
one tree to another that's the distance
in this graph and the distance since we
know we can get from anything to zero
and back again by into an n minus one
step so so 2 n minus 2 is a it is about
but there was a there's a there's a
paper that I just started reading a
couple hours ago by Vice later charging
and thurston where they they prove first
by a very nice simple argument that to n
minus 6 is it is uh always an upper
bound as long as n is is that Lee is
greater than 10 if so if you have a n is
11 or more you can always get from any
tree to any other in two and nine and
six rotations at most and then they
proved by an incredibly complicated
argument that for all four infinitely
many cases this bound is tight if there
are that for infinitely many values of n
there are trees with n nodes that are
exactly 2 n minus six apart in this
craft and they prove it for all end of
the form 10 times the perfect square
provided that this is this number is
greater than 2 to the 60th or something
like that so so it's been proved that
there are infinitely many cases but but
they conjecture is true for all and
greater than Ted and and it's known up
to N equals 20 by my calculation that
they totally the diameter of the scratch
is 2n minus six in all those cases so
there's got to be there's got to be a
combinatorial proof of this and they use
hyperbolic geometry anybody knows thurs
to make you not surprised that that's
the way you would do it and what I
suspect it what I suspect might be there
notin notes that are that are maximally
far apart are like this if you do a try
halation like this in a polygon in one
polygon and then you do a corresponding
one like this cutting across it in the
other then it seems to me that that's
going to take a lot of flips to get from
one to the other but proving proving it
is it might be might be difficult yeah
that so went by to summarize it anyway
this having this this lattice theory
knowledge is going to I think give us
more add yet more to our intuition about
binary trees and it's a it's a one of
these nice facts to know that that the
set of all binary trees actually has
late has an algebraic lattice structure
and that by looking further at this and
thinking about prime factorizations and
other things we work we can see new
things about reason we didn't see before
and this might be just the thing we need
to solve the next problem we need to
solve with with respect to x 9 32 not
okay